Well, good afternoon, everyone. I'm Tatum Tummins, senior
product manager at Kion.
If you're not familiar with Kon, we're
a FinOps and cloud ops enablement
tool focusing on automation and governance.
Uh, prior to coming over to the vendor side
of the space,
I spent over 7.5 years at a large
healthcare company doing FinOs.
I like to say I grew up in the industry in
a lot of ways. And I like to share that
because I'm passionate about the subject.
I'm passionate about helping people get better in their practice,
and that's ultimately why I'm here today to
talk about FinOps Plus, uh, an
effort that I think will help organizations
be more successful.
So when we look at what we're gonna do today,
we're gonna start with a quick level set
of what has the FinOps industry looked like
over the last year.
That will lead us into the 30,000
ft macro view of what FinOps Plus
is. And then I'll spend a few slides
getting into the more of the details of what that
looks like in action, some examples, uh,
and then we'll end with some next steps and takeaways.
Uh, but to start, it's important
we reflect on what the last year has looked like
in the industry.
And for those of you that are familiar with the FinOps
Foundation, uh, every year they do a
state of the FinOps survey where they ask folks like
you all,
what are your challenges, what are your priorities,
etc.
And in that survey, uh, at the
beginning of this year, folks came back and
said, hey, we got 3 main priorities
right now. It's reducing waste and optimizing
spend,
it's allocation of that cloud spend and
trying to get a little bit better at forecasting.
But what I found really interesting is when folks
were asked, well, what are you going to care about over the next
12 months?
Two new things enter.
The first is FinOps governance and policy at scale,
and the third was managing costs
beyond public cloud.
Those two things, along with
3 developments,
those 3 developments, the first being the introduction
of scopes.
So the FinOps Foundation introduced this
topic, which is essentially outlining the
different areas of your technology investment
that you can and should practice FinOs
on. The second is the
common billing schema of focus.
The 1.2 was released, and what we're
seeing is that practitioners
and vendors alike are starting to adopt
that schema or at least start to explore what that would
look like. And the last
piece, uh, and this should be obvious if you've
walked around anywhere this week, uh, AI
is everywhere, and the finOs
industry is no different.
So,
when I looked at that survey data,
and then I started to have conversations with prospects
and customers, I was starting to package,
you know, what are the areas that folks can start
to focus on of where FinOps is headed,
and.
Earlier this year,
uh, I met a gentleman, he's actually sitting right
back there,
uh, Matt Coffer from Insulate,
uh, and we met Matt, and
Matt came to us and said, hey,
you know, Insulate's looking for really two
things.
We want to get better vis visibility
into all of our technology spend. We
have all these SAS tools that we want to start bringing
in to have a single pane of glass.
And Matt also said, hey,
if we need to bring more governance and, and
more policy to our finOs practice.
And so, I thought about the survey data,
and I thought about what Matt was saying, and I
started to put this together.
And what Matt ultimately said, and you can scan that
QR code for a full case study,
is he said, we didn't just need FinOps, we needed FinOps
Plus. And so like any good
product manager, uh, I steal good ideas when
I see them,
and I decided, uh, to call this framework
FinOps Plus.
And ultimately, it's three pillars.
It's automated governance, it's AI
driven, and it's beyond public cloud.
And in a few slides, we'll show some
examples of what these look like in practice,
but I want to stay high level for a moment and
talk about what FinOps Plus is and is not.
So, it's a modern approach, and it's
really focused on doing 3 things,
solving challenges a little bit more proactively.
Driving efficiency.
And enabling smarter decisions.
And what it's really trying to do is take the things
that you all are doing today, the same challenges
and processes, and it's trying to make those
more successful right now, but what it's really
trying to do
is set you all up for success for where FinOps
is going over the next 12 to 18 months,
uh, as it evolves.
We think about what it's not.
It is by no means trying to redefine finops.
These three pillars are meant to apply to the same
processes that you're doing today.
It's also not trying to add more work to your plate.
If anything, it's trying to do the opposite by leaning
on automation, leaning on AI in the, in
strategic ways. It starts to give you more
time back in your day.
And then lastly, it's not just for certain maturity
levels.
There's gonna be some things in the next few slides that
for some of you may seem too mature or
too far-fetched, uh, but I promise,
and I'm confident that there's going to be something within
at least one of these pillars, uh, that
you can start to apply to your practice
leaving today.
And so with that,
let's talk about what these pillars look like in
action.
And so, the first we're gonna talk about
is automated governance.
And I like to start by defining
that with 3 steps.
The first is policy.
Policy becomes automation, and automation
becomes guardrails.
And when I talk about what policy means, I'll
throw some examples up that probably
apply to all of you.
Uh, policy looks like
how you want to define waste or what an orphaned
resource looks at your organization.
It looks like, what is your retention policy
for snapshots or storage?
It can be
what your lights off policy looks like for your
sandbox and dev environments. What time
do you shut those off? Are they off on the weekends? Things
of that nature.
And lastly, another simple example is tagging
your resources. Uh tagging is something
every FinOs practice does,
looks a little different everywhere, but the ability
to say these are the key value pairs we
look for, and then taking that policy
and using whether it's a homegrown solution
or a tool like Kion
and wrapping that up in automation.
When that happens, you start to have guardrails,
and those guardrails produce outcomes.
The first looks like preventing waste.
A simple example is waste is going
to exist at every organization,
but the time it takes for a human to intervene,
review those opportunities, and then take action
30, 60 days later,
you've had. Waste during that time period. So
the more that you can cut that off at the
very beginning,
you produce that waste or you reduce that waste,
and you also start to reduce manual work
because every time a human has to go
review an opportunity and then decide if they
can take action, that also takes away human
time and and the value that they could be providing
your organization.
And the last piece is really important. It
allows you to scale.
So as you scale in the cloud, it
gets more and more difficult to keep up with all
of these manual opportunities to remediate.
So by defining policy, putting automation
in place, you now start to have a scalable
process that as you grow, you can still maintain,
uh, and, and try to increase value.
The second pillar, AI driven, and this
is a fun topic, and I'm sure you guys are sick of AI
already this week, even on the first day.
Um,
there's a lot that we could get into here today,
and I, you know, there are some use cases in FinOs
that the AI we have today
may not be the perfect solution for, but what
I am confident is that in 3
areas, it's providing real
exciting value for folks, and those
are guidance, efficiency, and governance.
And so what I mean by guidance to start.
What you see on the screen here is Kon's
version of an in-app, uh, AI assistant,
and what I wanna draw your attention to is
that those are prompts on the screen.
And why I think that's so critically important
is that the cloud is complex,
fin-Os can be complex, and when you're
starting out and you just don't know where to go,
or maybe you're just a stakeholder and you're
in procurement or you're in finance or accounting,
and you need to find the data that you're looking for,
AI provides you a more usable way to find that
information. And then what's exciting is you click
on one of these prompts and it starts
to provide you additional questions that you might
should be asking yourself or highlighting things
for next steps.
And I think the usability piece of AI
is gonna go a long way in making FinOs
a little bit more of a cultural activity at your
organizations and not just something that one or two folks,
uh, know what they're doing.
The second piece, and this is probably the most obvious
one, we've, we've all experienced this probably personal
and professionally. Um, I use
chat GPT for cooking recipes
and proofreading emails, and we've probably all
had somewhat of an experience like that.
But it's not just the getting the
information a little bit quicker, uh, that I want to highlight
here, it's also getting tasks done a
little bit faster.
Uh, a great example is, uh, we
had an organization
who, when they go to update their budgets
on a monthly cycle,
uh, that process used to take them
about 45 minutes to an hour.
Now, using AI, that process
takes them less than 5 minutes, because they
have it go out.
And where they have overruns, where they need to adjust their
forecast, and in a single prompt actually
has the tool go drive and update to that budget
automatically instead of doing that over
50, 100 different projects and cost centers.
And so there's a lot there, um,
if you're interested in more use cases, specifically on efficiency,
I'd love to talk after this,
um,
but the next one is governance, and this is where
I'm most excited about,
because what I mean here is not governing
your. AI spend that is a piece of finops,
but that is not what this is.
This is actually using AI to
govern your cloud. And so what you
see on the screen over here
is, uh, I asked if
it could create a EBS
uh policy to help clean up my unattached
volumes. And what you see happening
is that in this particular use case,
um, it's writing this policy in cloud
custodian language, for those of you that are familiar with Cloud
Custodian.
And what it's done is without any
extra detail for me,
it's looking at any unattached volumes
for over 7 days. It's gonna take a snapshot
of those, and then it's going to delete those EBS
volumes. And in one prompt,
I now can use a tool
to go orchestrate that policy and
begin cleaning up EBS volumes, and
that's just one example, but when you think about.
What I was talking about prior with
automated governance, AI and automated
governance almost play off each other, um,
and there's a lot of power in this because
non-technical users who know
what they want to achieve, but don't know how to write those
policies or even where to begin,
can now start to lean in on AI to
do that for them.
If you saw the keynote this morning,
um, AWS announced. I'm, I'm gonna
blank on the name here, but they announced an
actual policy creator for their AI agents
and trying to actually prevent and provide guardrails
for that. And what they showed is the same concept
of asking AI
to make a prompt to govern your AI
spend, um, and we've seen a lot of, uh,
great success here, and I'm really excited for
where kind of this part of AI
and FinOps is going.
Then the third pillar,
beyond public cloud.
And so I talked about it a little bit under the
key developments, but FinOps is
expanding to all technology spend,
not just your public cloud.
And so it's the idea of the same
processes and the same practices that you're doing,
but applying them across
your SAS tool providers.
Your data center spend, your licensing spend,
or even your G AI spend.
And why that's important
is because
once you get that initial visibility,
you now have this single pane of glass, where
you're not only looking at your cloud spend, you're
looking at your Mongo DB spin, your data brick
spend, all in one dashboard.
And when you have that visibility,
now you can start to govern that spend,
you can start to optimize that spend.
And the last one's critically important,
you now make better business decisions because
you're not looking at
the cost of what a product or an application costs
just in the cloud. You're looking at what that cost
holistically, so you have a total cost of ownership,
you start to make better decisions on what
my app's profitability is, and etc.
And so to summarize what FinOps
Plus is,
it's trying to drive better outcomes,
and what it's trying to do is it's taking
those activities that you're already doing today,
your reporting, your budgeting, your optimization,
and it's doing those through these three pillars.
It's applying automated governance to
try to prevent waste before it exists.
It's using AI in strategic areas
to drive efficiency,
help you govern your cloud.
And it's using Beyond Public cloud to
make better decisions,
understand your total tech investment, um,
and what it's ultimately trying to do is
take that traditional finOs and bridge
it with operational excellence as
you scale and grow in the cloud.
So, for next steps,
uh, the first is
adopt FinOps Plus, and that's vague
on purpose, because it's gonna mean something different
to every single one of you, uh, here today.
Um, if you wanna talk more about your use
cases or what you found interesting, I'll be
over here to the side, would love to chat more. I'll
be at the Kayon booth, um, the rest of the
week, but.
My hope is whether it's uh a
SAS tool that you want to bring into your dashboard,
or it's an idea for a policy
that you really think would save a lot of money, if you could just
figure out a way to automate it, whatever it may
be, identify a next step, uh,
and I encourage you when you leave here today to,
to take action, uh, and try to
implement that at your organization.
The next, and I sincerely mean this, provide feedback
to me. So this is practitioner
customer driven content. This is
not from my brain, it's from the brain of people like Matt
back there, and it gets better
and more applicable to you all
when I hear your use cases. I, and if
those of you have any sort of uh disagreement
with something I shared today,
all of that's valuable in refining this
content and making it more usable, uh,
and accessible,
uh, to everyone.
And then lastly, if you found something here
interesting and you wanna really do a deep dive on any of those
use cases, uh, Kyon's booth is
just right over here, 1555,
um, would love to talk about this more,
show you how it can impact your organization or talk
through use cases that are specific to you,
um, and so with that, uh.
I know you guys could be anywhere this afternoon. You
might be headed to a happy hour or whatever it may be. I
genuinely appreciate you giving me 15 minutes,
hearing this content, uh,
myself, and then I think Matt, you're gonna come over there too
if anybody wanna ask questions and have further
conversations, but I really appreciate it and I hope you guys have
a great rest of the reinvent.